la richard anthony richard anthony lui
avait dit il y a trente ans vous verrez
ce qui est difficile et beaucoup grossir
vous verrez ce qui est difficile c'est
de durer trente ans après il prouve
qu'une fois de plus richard avait raison
mais si julien clerc
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter bien ça va en
parler de richard anthony effectivement
vous avez dit il ya 30 ans le plus dur
c'est dur et c'est vrai quand on n'a pas
réussi encore dans la carrière avec les
gens vous disent tu verras le plus dur
c'est dû aux attentes et chantier [ __ ]
c'est d'y arriver mais c'est vrai
qu'après on s'aperçoit que le plus dur
c'est effectivement de durée et richard
anthony ci s'est pas appliqué le
principe à lui mais en tous les cas en
ce qui vous concerne
il avait raison trente ans après de
toujours là si c'est quoi le secret la
bonne forme ce que je vous voyais là
attendre à côté de la grande caméra là
d'une minceur d'une visiteuse velde
comment vous faites je crois je fais
attention à ce que je mange pas de
cigarettes
pas d'alcool petit peu pas d'autres
drogues noms du sport
oui mais on m'a dit un truc que avant de
manger vous posiez vos aliments mais en
or mais c'est une rumeur à bout on m'a
dit jeudi est une invite tulle à vide à
la maison il arrive avec sa dalle en or
je n'amènerais pas chez vous à bord à
l'époque le diététicien que j'ai plus vu
depuis trois ans me disait heureusement
que je n'ai pas beaucoup comme vous en
liberté donc ça lui plaisait pas trop
que je passe tout comme ça ouais mais il
faut vous dire que comme il m'a fait un
truc diététique finalement donc j'étais
extrêmement simple c'est très très peu
de grâce et puis beaucoup de féculents
de légumes verts
la vraie question c'est est ce qu'il
vaut mieux vivre longtemps se faisait
chier ou moins longtemps en bouffant
n'importe quoi il le trouvait c'est que
je ne fais pas chier du tout ça nous en
a pas de pause et la boue n'ont avec une
nature qu'il faut avoir alors c'est un
bon petit julien clerc j'ai beaucoup
planqué l'être humain c'est vrai qu'on
très discret sur vous même je parle même
pas de vie privée mais sur vous êtes
allé pas comme ça au sentiment dans la
presse sa télévision
parce que vous mettiez la célébrité vous
êtes toujours métier la célébrité c'est
pas que je me méfie de ça mais c'est pas
j'étais content de faire ce métier est
ce que j'ai pas trop quoi faire d'autre
mais disons que dès que j'ai commencé
j'ai commencé tout
j'avais 20 ans je vais envie d'être
connue pour ce que je faisais alors pas
pas tellement pour les signes extérieurs
de de la célébrité c'est sympa aussi
mais ce qui m'importait dès le début
c'était d'être respectée pour la musique
quoi aimé pour ce que vous faites oui
mais alors là quand on fait de la promo
vous êtes bien obligé d'un petit peut
venir voir et les entendre c'est moi une
corvée qu'avant beaucoup moins ah bon
vous y prenez du plaisir maintenant -
presque vous savez faire ça quelle
discipline ce soir la dernière émission
de l'année chez perennial le gage mais
je sais de quoi tu sais quoi de gaz qui
viendra tout à leur place et pas un truc
j'espère que c'est pas un truc quand je
sais pas quoi non mené 6 jeux
je ne changerai pas
excuse
le vin
départ
on va
si je t'aime
elle n'arrête pas
hors sujet
pour la mélodie est comme d'habitude
très belle et les paroles on va en
parler sont pas mal non plus alors donc
esprit d'ouverture pour ce 18e album
nouveau pas relier d'autres compositeurs
que vous serez plutôt rare quand même et
puis orchestration nouvelle avec votre
nouvel ami lac à lille qui a quel âge
rallye il ya 23 ans 23 ans
alors lui ces foules mais qu'il est à
créteil donc il est co réalisateur de
l'album
ils sont à même maison de disques chez
virgin et un jour julien dit à la maison
dit j'aimerais bien un jeune mec comme
ça pour faire de la castration un peu
nouvelle et où il avait ce titre
qu'avait produit sa soeur
alors un jour ben virgin l'appel mais
qu'il était à créteil soleil quoi au
rayon charcuterie et puis on la calcule
pas cher quand même d'erreurs comme
c'est kelly louis comme ces rallyes
lingots dit il théorie en étage quand
même nous surveillons les sages vous
acheter son lait fermenté aux rayons
laitages et reconnu et voulu l'appeler
quoi donc le mec est d'être le choc de
sa vie comme halo c'est julien qui
apprécient une blague
oui oui l'afrique noire ils avaient été
prévenus avant par emmanuel de buretel
et voilà je les fais venir je vais
donner cette chanson là parce que
c'était quand même c'est s'arrêter assez
de voir ce qu'ils allaient faire lapsus
qui était relativement classique et
quand il est revenu avec la maquette
j'ai su tout de suite je vais faire tout
l'album avec lui lui la chance alors je
lui dit écoute je trouve que tu es un
jeune homme de grand talent et on va on
va faire tous tombés tout préparés ici
chez toi à créteil puisqu'il un petit
home studio là et puis après on va aller
aux états unis et on va prendre un grand
preneur de son tu vas me l'indiquer
puisque tu connais ça mieux que moi et
tu vas faire jouer sur des arrangements
tous ces musiciens dans tu vois les noms
sur les dix que tu achètes et c'est ce
qu'on a fait exactement
alors il ya lui puis à carla bruni
évidemment ex top model qui a fait les
paroles est alors votre votre épouse va
pas eu peur de voir travailler avec
je disais à ma femme demain je vais
bosser carla bruni j'aurai des soucis
quand même non ah non non elle est venue
beaucoup à la maison fait jamais texte
joint nom vous dit j'ai essayé mais je
t'ai mauvais j'ai pas de style ouais
mais ça c'est vrai j'ai plus eu de moins
qu'en même temps un geste lucide
ah oui il ya plein de gens qui n'ont pas
cette lucidité qui continue à écrire
vous moi vous savez j'ai fait des
milliers de gens ce pardon il a vu trop
longue
non mais c'est vrai dit j'ai même du mal
à écrire une lettre
alors je vous dis à chaque fois que je
vois mais je vous le redis encore une
fois c'est qu'en fait effectivement on
parle beaucoup de votre au parolier on
ne parle pas assez à mon sens du melody
ce que vous êtes
alors là on va écouter en deux fois si
on est obligé de faire en deux fois avec
vous il ya tellement de mélodies enfants
deux fois en fait de petits paquets de
un postulant
tu
g
mais ma préférence sera moi
oui je sais cette indifférence qui sa
défense fait souvent en compte l a
remise
me de faïence de faïence je sais ça des
failli avaler
ce produit est
volley ah bon
non
je suis
oh
jouera
je vous
à
mais
mais vous
la ville
estag je suis connu le
pas tous mais tous
je veux être utile
là ce qui monte mais à ceux qui m'aiment
rond
et à ceux qui me mène
les dernières si je t'ai je ne changerai
pas
en exclu
je lui à coeur
pardon je les reconnais une selle pour
la pluie pour les tampons c'est vrai que
ces chansons là car cette publicité qui
a relancé l'agencement ouais c'est vrai
qu'à relancer le temps bon ben ali s'est
pas julien clerc qui confond toujours là
j'arrive bien alors j'essaie de
comprendre comment tout sable c'est vrai
que vous êtes vais quand même un talent
exceptionnel et comment c'était arrivé
c'est vrai qu'au départ les femmes une
opposition entre deux styles de vie donc
de style de musique qui ont créé à la
rencontre des deux c'est un peu comme
les beatles quand ils font du rock and
roll et puis d'un jour encontre georges
martin qui leur dit voilà il ya le
hautbois il ya le violoncelle long qui
commence à mélanger le rock'n'roll avec
des instruments compliqué et vous
effectivement il ya à la fois une
inspiration
j'irai française très classique est à la
fois vos origines guadeloupéennes même
si c'est loin fondé ce sens comme ça de
la mélodie à travailler tous de la
musique classique au liban une formation
classique sous george cdh et harmonique
la cij
au départ il ya deux familles votre
famille paternelle inspecteur des postes
le père de votre père donc qui est veuf
qui élève son fils à la force du poignet
un cercueil je crois que ma sa femme
meurt comme mon père est jeune et mon
grand père paternel était quelqu'un
quelqu'un assez austère qui travaillait
comme vous dites dans les postes dont
toute la jeunesse de mon père c'était
des études travaillant de cannes il a
fait normale sup en face dure c'est
quelqu'un qui est élevé comme ça dans ce
sens là et en face alors c'est assez
minces comme le film de chaque pièce
quoi sert qu'en face c'est une autre
famille beaucoup plus folklo fonctionne
une maternelle à ressasser les antilles
et votre votre père qui guadeloupéen
grand père maternel mon père oui
guadeloupéen il
il est communiste aussi oui il est venu
pour regarde 14 il est resté mais
surtout vous n'avez pas tort de dire en
face c'est que c'est vraiment de l'autre
côté de la rue c'est la rue poirier
denard c'est qu'une petite rue dans
quatre ans - et ma grand mère maternelle
vient faire le ménage c'est mon grand
père paternel
c'est insensé et leur compte et devient
l'emmène sa fille et petite fille est
tout petit et qui vient chez les leclerc
alors le fils leclerc lui prête ses
stylos des crayons son papier et donc il
dessine tous les deux voies la finlande
en huile à 15 ans il fait ses devoirs
sérieux et et puis la petite fille à
côté pour qu'elle lui foute la paix
pendant que ma grand mère fait le ménage
il lui donne des crayons papier puis la
guerre arrive et on revient et cette
belle jeune fille valhalla grandi et
voilà c'est comme une histoire comme un
roman j'adore ça ce sont des sites us
des romans elle est ma vie est un roman
on pourrait dire et c'est vrai dire que
là il revient de la guerre il trouve
cette petite gamine qui dessinaient être
une jolie jeune fille il épouse ben les
enfants l'enfant qui n'essaie vous voilà
c'est paula alors paul c'était votre
père alain c'était votre mère et leclerc
c'était votre nom alors évidemment ne
sont déjà pas d'accord sur le prénom de
leur fils donc ça présage rien de bon
pour bien me dire il se sépare quelques
quelques années plus tard je dois avoir
un an un an et demi s'est pas beaucoup
plus tard et dans votre père lui il ya
une bo gars dans certains il ya aux
fonctionnaires à l'unesco
alors là il va habiter dans une maison
là voilà on est en plein film de
chatiliez là c'est à dire que la vie est
un long fleuve tranquille dans la maison
aux molière ah bon la boa pour la reine
et l'autre côté avec la belle-mère qui
scella vous apprenez la musique était
formidable une vieille chanson française
la musique classique et où surtout la
musique classique avait pas de
télévision peu de radio la musique
classique et qu'on chante avec mes
frères et soeurs autour du piano temps
en temps le soir des chansons françaises
et vient il s'en sort alors du côté de
boeck mer c'est passionnant versa c'est
le jazz et le blues est comme mon
grand-père de valverde
dernis pour sa retraite elle continue de
vivre dans ce petit appartement les
femmes seules secrétaire de direction et
je les revois pendant les week-ends et
lie à la télé les disques de chansons et
c'est autre chose
tout ça est alors comme quoi chez tout
artiste c'est une fêlure au départ et
quelque part quelque chose qui s'est mal
passé vous ces déchirements du
du dimanche soir quand vous retournez de
la porte d'orléans à bourg-la-reine à
pied depuis je déteste l'hiver on prend
prenez le métro pour marcher de de la
gare de bourg la reine jusqu'à la maison
et avait comme ça 20 minutes oui là je
voyais ma mère pleurait effectivement
certes j'ai détesté l'automne une odeur
dans l'automne en banlieue pas dans les
banlieues je dois dire d'ailleurs plutôt
les banlieues il ya des marronniers en
fait c'est un des odeurs qui me suivront
certainement toute ma vie et je déteste
ça l'arrivée de l'hiver tous à l'automne
on est comme ma mère pleurait quand elle
n'aura comme ça jusqu'à la maison vous
vivez dans deux mondes complètement
opposées d'un côté les l'influencent
antillaise avec le foin que colombo la
confiture d'ananas l'autre côté de votre
père qui était gaulliste
ouais assez assez assez pur et dur et
votre c'est l'évasion ou par rapport à
ces deux univers c'est la musique quand
arrivent les rives les beatles arrive là
j'ai pu écouter quand on m'a offert
j'avais mes parents avaient choisi comme
parrain un juif un monsieur qui était
radiologue juifs roumains et évidemment
il avait un enfant unique et alors il me
gâte est énormément j'étais arrive il y
avait pas mal d'argent alors c'est lui
le premier qui m'a offert un poste
transistors alors après ben au lycée
lakanal ya un peu tantinet qui s'appelle
socrates qu'ils initient à la batterie
et là vous jouez dans des groupes vous
dites c'est davantage d'avoir un côté
bourgeois c'est le côté bourg la reine
ça vous jouez dans les rallyes dont vous
faites un peu ou faites un peu de thunes
être quand j'avais des copines et des
copains qui étaient qui était tout ce
truc des réalistes et bien enfin si
j'écoutais pas tellement ce qu'on jouait
ce n'était pas très bon on joue un peu
mieux disait socrate
pour hâter sciences po à cause de léon
blum et puis après vous allez la fac à
essentielle avec votre pote de lakanal
maurice vallet vous essayer à composer à
la composition déjà et vous reprenez le
piano vous aviez abandonné à l'âge de 13
ans et plus est et comment ça ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment vous êtes pris
conscience qu'on pouvait écrire des
mélodies mais je sens ça s'est passé je
vais vous dire que quand j'ai repris le
piano tout seul évidemment je voulais
plus de profs comme j'en avais eu ni de
solderie pas entendre parler de solfège
je faisais que des trucs à l'oreille et
comme vous en doutez bien j'aime et des
musiques étaient des musiques pas facile
donc j'essayais comme je pouvais de
reproduire les accords mais quand il
fallait reproduire thelonious monk ou
bobby timmons qu ils sont les grands
pianistes de jazz j'avais le plus grand
mal tu n'avais pas les clés de cette
musique donc évidemment un jour en
cherchant rassemblement sur un truc de
tonus manque ou de dylan ou des beatles
je sais plus je crois que de guerre
lasse je suis fier de trouver de la
musique pour boire et se pense vraiment
que mains ma vie a basculé jour je me
suis rendu compte
vous pouviez composé composer sa dont il
sera la mère de pouvoir composer des
mélodies
j'ai pris conscience un jour vous muriel
que vous aviez un don ou petit à petit
ça commençait dans la voiture en faisant
rire donc il m'a intéressé c'est celui
de la musique que j'écoutais je m'étonne
jouer pareil ouais vous savez que joue
de la batterie vachement bien j'ai vu
jouer un jour satisfaction ah bon c'est
pas c'est pas une grande technicienne
mais elle a une énergie l'après inergie
débatteurs
allons-nous canon
alors vous êtes le seul ici à l'avoir vu
jouer raconte alors un jour placé la
scène alors fondatrice de l'histoire est
rangé comme sa mère elle est comme est
obligé de réparer le décor c'est d'y
arriver
non mais c'est vrai un jour les
histoires comme c'est extraordinaire ça
aussi dans money la vie des gens ça me
fait sinon je vous êtes à la sorbonne
pas à côté de la sorbonne dans un petit
café qui s'appelle l'écritoire vous êtes
incapable d'écrire des paroles avec vale
vous vous levez comme ça et vous dites
je suis chanteur qui veut écrire mes
chansons et à ce moment là quelqu'un qui
écrit départ voilà
et le mec il répond c'est roda gil mais
là c'est fou mais qui se laisse et roda
gil est en train de faire les petits
portraits façon cocteau sur une table ça
nous aide animateur
déjà ils veulent être des futurs jeux du
monde sûrement il dit moi c'est parti
à bâle
là
pas mal
il
ma musique est là
et
kanabeach est là
je n'ai pas
lien
mais qu'ils y croient
obama
non
turin
des mamans
non
m
parent
de l'aveyron
que je peux
je
lui non
aucun n'est pas dans ce sens là
parra
elle coule dans mes veines
bada
si on chantait
vous la gauche l'appel veut ni voir
j'aurais
dans l'ue
et voilà non